[Music]
soon there wouldn't be any kids anywhere
the government wasn't afraid of what
happened to the ones that didn't make it
they were afraid of us because the ones
that survived changed Lu Bu are very
rare among the most powerful
we're going to a place where kids can
live together on the outside the only
people who would ever help us for us
whatever happens don't stop for their
safety in yours please turn over your
children this morning to know you're
hiding and you're smart enough to be
high
I just want you to be afraid of me the
more that I try to control it
more damage that I do
I can show you how to use your strengths
the way they're meant to be used
[Music]
we can fight back
we don't have to stay in darkness
we've survived all of this
I will fight for all of us
[Music]
I have to stay for work father I never
see here your life is happening now
right in front of you I'm sorry what to
do what to do what to do indeed Oh
Christopher Robin oh you're here in
London I haven't seen you in years
I've lost all of my friends we need to
find them are you on an expedition so
people can't see moving and talking but
why just try and be elastic super into
you looks to Burak to play a naptime
I love play well let's see it like this
well duh
house clouds Treville
waiter oh please say what you see but
could you say what you see a little more
quietly house grass
[Music]
Christopher Robin he's giant dope and he
smells a little funny
[Music]
just an average Wednesday morning
it's always a sunny day when Christopher
Robin comes to play silly old bird
Disney's Christopher Robin rated PG get
tickets now and oh man whatever is gonna
start shooting bill 1 what you've got
and they'll kill each and every one of
us until they get it
[Music]
somebody totally gets in the corner all
I need to break today I'm 30 years old
I wear a Hawaiian shirt for my boyfriend
dumped mean attacks let's set it on fire
we just want to talk about drew Thayer
he's your boyfriend right I'm sorry what
I know you're a spy
it's a long story I will explain
everything to you forehead some bad
people are after me another after you if
we don't deliver this package you've had
a lot of people are gonna die
you want to die having never been to
Europe or do you want to go to Europe
and die having been to Europe
why are those my only two options
[Music]
international terrorist group is buying
a series of assassinations a lot of
innocent people are gonna die unless
you're something who you trust has to
help you this is real and I honestly
think I'm shocked woman you are
incredible and I want you to own it
[Music]
you have a real instinct for this have
you ever felt so low I ain't high okay
[Music]
without you and then we both be dead
[Music]
what you're the boss
and yet who have not sacrificed one
ounce of femininity that is the Beyonce
of the government
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's a monster outside
[Music]
what you people discovered is bigger
than we ever thought was how big is that
thing what's the largest trunk that ever
existed a living fossil thought had been
extinct over two million years
my god
it's Megalodon he's kidding right
[Music]
[Music]
that things have death need to find it
and kill it I just put a tracker on it
you guys ever watched Shark Week
[Music]
he looks heroic but it's kind of kind of
negative attitude
she owned this you ugly
[Music]
okay Twitter poll if you could stay one
age forever what would it be what about
the age we are right now seriously
sometimes I wish we could just get out
of the stupid town together
[Music]
[Applause]
the dogs asked me you wanted to know if
she ever talked about running away check
this out
here's the last site she visited
Slenderman he preys on innocent youth I
think this is how he get Katie back
those who hear the three bells toll
accept his invitation when you hear the
first you must close your eyes opening
your eyes
only once you heard the third he gets in
his head like a virus
some mio takes some drugs math
once you see him you can't see him
[Applause]
folks we are certainly in the dog days
of summer it's gonna be 375 keep the
change
this is $1.00 there you look beautiful
your dog pregnant or just super fat I
called you for pizza not a baby
just my kids don't like old people he's
lethargic cuz appetite is down Sam needs
to get out there and meet some new dogs
that'll be $300
I found her yesterday pregnancy has
changed your sister move away from the
door she is a regular - you keep my dog
alive until I get back from the hospital
my building it's a strict no-dog policy
so how am I gonna get you up there
but it'd be possible to like volunteer
yes joining us today is a former la ramp
the co-host hosting a morning new show
the audience tops you two together try
every spot you've snip on this wall is
the same just wanna help you find your
dog you can't be my best friend this dog
has made us a family
almost don't recognize without steam
coming out to you
landlord just salt the building out from
under us we got the new tricks charity
events we'll come on down open their
hearts to us to love and to be loved
tonight find that beautiful
[Music]
oh that's just my right you've been
dating for over a year now and I think
it's about time people met my beautiful
girlfriend what about us taking an
adventure II like Queens Singapore
Colleen's wedding do you want to be my
family every time I bring them up to
kiss maybe his parents are poor and he
has to send their money pick up bags and
get you checked into first I can't
afford this so your family is rich we're
comfortable that is exactly what a super
rich person would say one point two
minutes yeah there's just the biggest
developers in all of Singapore Beijing
bachelors these people aren't just rich
they're crazy rich you really should
have told me that you're like the
principal innovation that's ridiculous
much more of a hurry
mum this is Rachel truth she just thinks
you're some like unrefined banana
there's a few fingers no on the outside
or white on the inside so I chose to
raise a family for me it was a privilege
but for you you may think it's
old-fashioned
don't you want next be happy I know
you're not what Nick needs she's like
trying to play games chicken with me
thinking I'm gonna swerve like a chicken
but you can't flirt you know whoa luck
and be like bok-bok [ __ ]
okay maybe not as aggressive
I met a girl I fell in love and I want
to marry her your Nicholas young you're
untouchable but Rachel's not if you
prepped Rachel to face the walls I
really admire you takes guts coming all
the way over here facing expanding I
know this much you will never be enough
yo it's about time someone stood up to
Aunt Eleanor well you not me Oh God
Chicago is over here
[Music]
[Applause]
ever since I can remember my family has
been my whole life
Rachel Rachel if Nikki chose me even
those his family and if he chose his
family he might spend the rest of his
life for Zen ting you you dad you got a
nice you got nastier at the end of the
last ice age when our world was a harsh
and unforgiving place
and a boy who was separated from his
family
[Music]
sound a Worf separated from its back
[Music]
together
they forged a bond
that would change the course of human
history this log is
[Music]
experience the incredible story
of how mankind discovered man's best
friend
[Music]
alpha experienced their journey in
theaters this obvious according to the
government we do not exist over very
real but not predictable highly trained
and we save millions alive if we fail
there is no backup plan we are overwatch
but we get things done my government is
planning an attack on the United States
can I trust you looking on a plane I
give you everything deliver that package
to here mile 22 are you I'm totally calm
that's because you're mentally unstable
thank you contact major contacts get out
is there
you keep coming to me to tell us all
that's a weird game you can play what's
he got on pull it to the top mile 22
August 17th in my Maxim
[Music]
[Applause]
someone there let me get this out
alright introducing Axl the latest in
military protection featuring facial
recognition on board weapon systems and
owner pairing capabilities it's paired
now the cake is some control of the
entire project you want to play all
right let's go
I want to show you something hello
listen talk to it yeah stay
sugar boy use of everything I said but
it
somebody spent a little lot of money on
them they gotta village and flora I
don't think it's owner deserves to get
them back
I need to know what it's doing it's
evolving way beyond expectation that's
my dog I want it back
loves the drugs
come on you needs our help
what you should do is turn it in it's
not finders keepers you got to stay down
all right
it's a robot an intelligent robot he
feels things
sending you the new location move in for
retrieval
[Music]
or lose together
[Music]
[Music]